Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and today
I want to talk about learning words.
Uh, why?
Well, one reason is that, uh, I
started up polish about 10 days ago,
and I was notified by LingQ that
I now know 36,000 words in Polish.
Uh, I didn't do 30, didn't
learn 36,000 words in 10 days.
Uh, back in 2015, I, I can't remember
if it was three months or six months,
but certainly I was very active during a
three month period, uh, with Polish and
doing a lot of Polish history, starting
of course with our mini stories and,
and simpler content, and then building
up to, to the history, uh, of Poland,
which was of great interest to me.
But this reminded me, wow, 36,000.
I don't necessarily speak that
well, but I understand a lot.
I have a base in the language and it
reminded me that, um, I've always felt
that the simplest measure of our level in
the language doesn't necessarily mean our
ability to speak, but our level in that
language, our potential in that language
is the number of words that we know.
And so that's what I want to talk about
today, how do we learn these words?
What does it mean to know words?
Uh, and so forth.
I remember when I wrote my book back in
2003, uh, the Linguist on Language: A
Language Learning Odyssey, I remember
saying two things there that at that
time I felt very strongly about.
This was before I had ever heard of
Stephen Krashen and the input hypothesis
before I had heard of the three keys:
your attitude, the time you spend with
the language and the ability to notice.
I didn't know any of those things,
but I felt that two things were at
least part of my success in learning
Chinese, which I learned in less than
a year, up to a level of, let's say
4,000 characters reading newspapers,
translating from Chinese to English,
from English to Chinese, uh, you know,
newspaper editorials and things like that.
That one was intensity, and the other
was the number of words I had to learn.
The sort of Gordian Knot measurement
of where you stand in the languages,
the number of words, you know, and
that's why when we built LingQ, we
built into it this measurement of words.
Words that you save, which is the number
of LingQs created, and words that you
know, which means words that the system
has decided that you already know.
Now, sometimes when I say this I
get criticism because, you know,
what does it mean to know a word?
Uh, you don't know the
full scope of the word.
Uh, you can't use the word.
All of this is true, but those
things are also difficult to measure.
What we can measure at LingQ is whether
you looked up the word in a given text.
If you didn't look it up, the
assumption is, you know it.
And so the process for me of learning
words is not sort of pouring over lists,
studying, uh, vocabulary, feeling that
sort of urgency to learn this vocabulary.
Those activities are
largely self-defeating.
The more you review your, um, at least
in my own experience, flashcards,
the more you review lists, the
less is sticking in your brain.
The more you just expose yourself to
content reading and listening and just
throwing these words into your brain,
eventually those words will start
to initially become known and then
eventually you'll be able to use them.
So how does it work?
So at LingQ, all the words are blue.
At first, you look up the words
you don't know, and I see it as
kind of taking those blue words
and throwing them into my brain.
And the minute they're into
my brain, they're now yellow.
In other words, I've clicked on them.
They have become LingQs.
Uh, in time these yellow LingQs in
my brain and also in my database
at LingQ will convert themselves
into known words, because in time I
will read, say other contexts where
that yellow word appears again.
Or I will save words that are very
similar, and because these similar
words are kind of side by side, all
of a sudden I start to know them.
In fact, increasingly, words
that I have never seen before
that are similar to words that I
know, I throw them in my brain.
Or they automatically get into my brain.
I don't even have to save them.
And so that my vocabulary grows,
it grows because I do a lot of
listening and reading and so it's
kind of a mutual relationship.
The, uh, more you read and the more
you listen, the more words you know.
Therefore, this measurement of how many
words you know, or have looked up is a
measurement of your level of activity.
It typically means that you have
read a large number of words.
You have listened to a lot of,
uh, the language, because I
always listen to what I'm reading.
And again, you can see this
from my statistics at LingQ.
Unfortunately, um, initially when
I, I start into a language, I use
content in our LingQ library, but
increasingly I import content from
elsewhere and therefore I have the
text in LingQ and that enables link
to measure my activity in LingQ.
But typically the audiobook, the
audio for that is somewhere else.
So I'm doing that in iTunes or I'm
doing it in, uh, maybe the audiobook
app and therefore, I'm not measuring it
automatically at LingQ, but typically
knowing a lot of words means that you
have thrown a lot of words into this
database, into this memory reserve.
Even if you can't retrieve them,
slowly those words are going to
become, even initially you're gonna
forget that you ever saw the word,
but it's already in your database.
It's already in your reserve,
and over time it become a white
word, which means you kind of
understand it in most contexts.
And in time some of those words will
become, you know, words that you can use.
So to me, this is sort of the fundamental
task is, is gathering all these
words, coming across them in different
contexts, throwing them into your
brain, letting them gradually evolve
naturally into words that you understand.
And eventually, and I should say, you
understand and you gradually get a,
a better sense of the, the scope of
meaning of those words, you get a better
sense of which words are used with the
words that you've put into your brain.
So just heave them in there
and don't worry about them.
Don't worry about forgetting them.
Just throw them into your brain.
Uh, and that to me is the process.
Now, some people may say, uh,
what's the point of knowing so
many words if you can't speak?
Uh, and obviously whatever
we do in language learning
is a function of our goals.
So if I have a limited sort of demand
of, you know, what I need to be
able to do in a certain language,
uh, I wanna focus in on being
able to have simple conversations,
then I can limit my vocabulary
to, um, you know, a limited range.
It'll work in a lot of situations.
Unfortunately, the native speaker may
use words that are outside the range
of words that you have tried to focus
on, and where you have developed an
ability to converse in that limited
range, but it certainly serves a purpose.
But that is not typically
what I aspire to do.
I aspire to acquire a lot of words
because typically what I'm going to
be able to do with the language that
I'm learning is listen and read.
Read about history as I'm doing now.
I'm, it's, it's just fascinating.
I'm reading and listening to a book
about the history of Poland, starting
basically at the time of the partition
of Poland through to modern times.
It's very interesting.
I did the same with Danish, so
that's a big part of my enjoyment
of the language when I go to Poland.
I wanna speak and of course, the
more I speak the better I will speak.
Uh, I will leave you a video
of me, uh, speaking in Polish
when I was active in 2015.
Can I do as well now?
I don't know.
I just had a person contact me through,
through, uh, Twitter and Skype, and we had
a brief conversation in halting Polish.
I think, you know, I've been
at Polish now for 10 days.
Uh, it'll be two months of working
with Polish before I get to Poland.
I think I'll be able to do quite well
and I will certainly, uh, make a video
when I'm in Poland, but I'm realistic,
you know, I will have a week in Poland.
My polish will improve while I'm there.
And then when I come home and I no
longer speak Polish regularly, my
Polish ability to speak will decline,
but I will still have the vocabulary
that I acquired and I can always go
back as I'm doing now, go back to what
I studied, uh, in 2015, or explore new
material where a lot of the words that
I saved, that I threw into my brain
that became yellow and possibly white.
A lot of these words will
naturally reappear in the new
content that I'm learning from.
And so all of the words that I've
saved and put into my reserve,
I have those, those are mine.
My ability to converse will fluctuate.
And so therefore, to me, the
my measurement, the simplest
measurement of where I am in a
language is how many words I know.
Uh, how many words I put into my reserve,
my ability to speak, particularly in, in
those languages where I haven't spoken
a lot it's gonna fluctuate 'cause I've
said many times to be very good on
the language you have to speak a lot.
And those languages that I speak
the best where I lose, you know,
less of my ability to converse.
Those are the languages
that I've spoken a lot.
And so Poland, it's not because
of one week in Poland gonna
fall into the category of
languages that I've spoken a lot.
But I think by focusing in on
words, listening and reading, I'm
learning a lot about the country.
It's gonna make my visit
there much more rewarding.
I'm going to be able to
converse with people in Polish.
Uh, my ability to speak will improve
while I'm there, and then it'll start to
decline again unless I decide to spend
a lot of time, uh, working on Polish
and neglecting Persian and Arabic in
the other languages that I'm working on.
So there you have it.
Learning words shouldn't be stressful.
It shouldn't be a deliberate activity.
It should be a part of your gradual
immersion into the language, the
culture, the history, and all those
things that make every language
so, thank you for listening.
Bye for now.